あっこ笹ずれちゃったですみなさん一応疎遠欲しくないですか
僕は
ほしいですね思ってないですよあその僕も給料制の男なんて持ってないんですけども
1兆円で実際やったらどんなものなのか皆さん見たことないと思うんですよ僕がないん
ですがしいて言うなら何かまぁあの100倍の200万300万とかったらショー
ティーでテレビとかで見たことあるんですけどもこれも重くても頭の1000万とか
2000万とかだった気がせめて僕の記憶が正しけれ本当の会1億円だって皆さん
いたことないと思ってまして僕も動画で家1億円のなんか偽物ぽいの作ってみたんです
けどもドッキリであの結局保護なく偽物紙っぺらだってなんかうまい水とかだから適当
なんで表当社で1億円分の重さとかはその量じゃないかも知れた数え一見のですぐに
準備できないから一体どうしようかといったときにすごいことをしているところがあり
ました皆さんも1億円でいっぷりかといったら出てくると思う
けどもうがありましたりましたすごい中前あったら何に使いますか
仙台発租税教育よ教材机目プリカ発売しております
販売一時1500ちゃんと売れてるっぽいですねうわあすげえなんかいろんな使い方が
あるポイントで学校での教育とかよねばお金を実例を見せるって言うからもあると思う
んですよねというわけで私ゲットしました胃腸炎ので
不日課持ってきます右ますね
待ってやばい結構皆さんの想像絶する重さだと思います
どうやってこれが1億円のレイプ2ヶ月は早速あげないことを思います
ヌーだーっをすると株式会社幸栄舎さんちょっとよくわかんない粗茶7年したかと言い
ますと
2ぷっ
49,500円ばそりゃそうでしょうね1億円を性別に作るつったらそのルーラー8日
で各は言います
うわあうわあああっ
濃いヒゲあずっ
デブなんか胸がドキドキしてきましたうおおおお
年齢くださいベースちゃんとしてますよこれまずく感じの1億円かけてきてますけど
これいいんですかーでめっちゃがちな感じでてますけどこれいいんですかーつーわけで
早速うっ分けてみようと思いますじゃあこれでもね俺あんたわかってないんですよね
ちゃりやい直にだったら動画でもつけろそうじゃなかったちょっとん
厳しいところがあると思っていますただ純正に直感ってどんなもんなのかなっていうの
を感じてみたい説はあるって下げてみようと思います
アンパ
[音楽]
ねいやだろう4 haze の財布に緒言なんちゃって
みてくださいか書いてあると思うんですけども本当にリアルに1億円が実際にあったら
どういうものなのっていうのを再現しているレプリカらしいですすごい大さんの重さも
リアルって事はもう本当に2分やったこれですからねまあ高はうーんまあ
わー
なんだねでね保護
違うじゃあーなるほどでこういう感じなんですね多分
これはねぇこれは100万円ですねちょっと残念なことにめっちゃ見本て書いてあり
ますね
ぜひ100万円町でくらいなんですああーっ
本当貯金があったらこんなもんらしいです
塩分日本って書いてやがるしてい3丁検便の大きさとって見たことあるんですけど多
さってたかわかんなかったから放送
赤尾も直墓を燃やす号
ba から離しちゃダメって書いてんだから話はできないですけど本当に思えない強く
言って
うーん
うわぁすっげぇがやるって言ってました筋トレに使えそうですねこれいいやーすごいは
なんかときりとかに使うとしたんですけど日本って書いてあるからやや苦めな気がし
ちゃったよな
たらほんと者のズーニーパペンってどんなもんなんだろうという気持ちでちょっと買わ
せていただきました
そういう音札束ペロランプに入って何度見たくなるんですよ
俺はなんかとなるんじゃないってから9人が竹簡出てきたと思うんですよこれ
こんな重いんだねやもうなんかさんのさーん
あの重さとか見た目はこんな感じになってわかったんですけども
ちょっと美穂って書いてあるからドッキリには向かない皆さんに直径ってこんな感じな
んだよっていうのを今日伝えたかっただけなんよ
すまんそれ以外は何もないと言いたいとこだったんですけどもせっかくこんな音である
がトラックリアルな重さ曲げた駿
関目が悪い人であれば日本亭まず紙になって一緒に寝もんで1兆円って思っちゃうかも
しれない
一つ雑に毒気にやっていこうと思います猫
[音楽]
ブーバーし
1億円くらいじゃない